et puis pas aidé à passer pour est
toujours en place
donc c'est parce que pour sa famille
surtout qui est loin d'être aussi tout
ce qu'on peut faire c'est pour elles
qu'elles soient dans de très bonnes
conditions
c'est une des nôtres avant tout qu'ils
aient disparu c'était un peu une
référence pour toute la jeunesse
sénégalaise aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'elle est en train de faire est ce que
les uns dans de bonnes conditions est ce
qu'elle mange tout ça c'est des
questions que nous nous posons en cinq
graves de la nécessité que la france
fasse quelque chose pour notre cher
compatriote
[Musique]
système vraiment partant banque a fait
de moi aujourd'hui la fille que je suis